la pluie n'aura pas entamé leur
détermination à l'appel de plusieurs
associations
ils étaient une centaine ce samedi place
du capitole à toulouse pour sensibiliser
les pouvoirs publics sur la question du
logement alors que la trêve hivernale
touche à sa fin une période qui offre
chaque année un peu de répit à des
milliers de foyers menacés d'expulsion
aujourd'hui les associations créent une
pire l'année dernière à cause de la
crise sanitaire
le gouvernement a mis certaines mesures
en place qui ont reporté en fait les
expulsions de l'année dernière donc ça a
diminué en fait le nombre d'expulsions
l'année dernière mais ces expulsions
lasser les familles qui devaient être
expulsés l'année dernière il n'y a eu
aucune mesure en fait concrète et réelle
qui ont permis de régulariser leur
situation
et donc ces familles restent toujours un
an plus tard expulsables donc aux
familles aux personnes qui sont
nouvellement expulsables cette année
s'ajoute celle de l'année dernière qui
n'ont pas été exclus table une situation
tendue qui semble s'aggraver à toulouse
une ville où les logements sociaux sont
insuffisants et où les loyers ont doublé
en dix ans
dans ces conditions les plus fragiles
doivent parfois se tourner vers des
marchands de sommeil ou investir
illégalement des habitations
pourtant des solutions existent
li a plus de 200 mille mètres carrés de
bureaux vides à toulouse ce serait quand
même l'occasion de taper du poing de
dire voilà ces deux endroits inoccupés
on a besoin de toi
et donc on longe ray donc les gens qui
sont recensés dans toutes les
associations et qui ont besoin de toi
juste pour vivre dignement pas utiliser
justement les les
les gros chantiers de construction pour
relier de faire des appartements de
priver de luxe pensait plus à faire des
hlm
d'après la fondation abbé pierre ce sont
trente mille familles qui risquent
d'être expulsés en france soit près de
66 mille personnes malgré les demandes
répétées des associations la ministre du
logement emmanuelle wargon a refusé de
prolonger la trêve hivernale jusqu'au 20
juillet comme l'année dernière
après la première vague de co vide mais
la ministre dit souhaiter une reprise
méprisé des expulsions il ne peut y
avoir d'année blanche en terme
d'expulsion ni de moratoire nous sommes
en train de refonder complètement la
gestion de la fin de la trêve hivernale
avec une reprise des expulsions de
manière échelonnée prioriser en
proposant un relogement ou au moins un
hébergement aux personnes expulsées
alors que les expulsions vont bien
reprendre les 43000 places d'hébergement
temporaire mise à disposition des sans
abri depuis mars 2020 seront prolongées
de dix mois pour faire face aux
conséquences de la pandémie
personne ne sera mis à l'arrêt nous
allons conserver ce niveau historique de
200 mille places d'accueil grâce au
maintien de ces 43000 places jusqu'en
mars prochain
des annonces qui ne semble pas apaiser
les associations bien décidé à
poursuivre leurs manifestations